uh my next question I want to delve
into uh is music cuz you mentioned
getting the band back together just as a
joke right so in um in Islam music is
Haram music is impermissible okay again
we often hear people say you know in
Western Society but you know music gets
you so much closer you know to sometimes
to spirituality and it's such a
spiritual thing and you know and we know
in Islam music evokes em
right and the Quran comes as a way of
recitation sometimes it sounds musical
although we don't say it's musical but
it gives us it gives us a feeling of
spirituality so so to speak that is
different to that of music so you know
some of the scholars even said that
music is the Quran of the shaan right of
the devil so why is
Islam uh considered music even though
there's some because I could understand
right some people say okay there's
gangster rap there's you know reggae
music we have some some bad regular
music but we have some music that might
be quote unquote soing to the soul right
it's it's it calms the individual so why
is all music considered impermissible in
Islam and why don't we indulge in
it
music you know repeating you know words
over and over again in this type of way
you know uh the lyrics that are involved
the message that is involved you know
the effect that it has on the mind it
weakens the mind
it weakens the mind it weakens the
memory you know and it is uh it's a
sugar pill to cover over you know
certain matters of Sadness and Sorrow
and so on and so forth you know we don't
have a need for music you don't have a
need for music there's no need for music
you know and the harms of it away the
benefits so this could be said about you
know previous thing about alcohol and
various types of intoxicant and so on
and so forth you know same said about
music you know that music is
intoxicating music intoxicates the mind
and usually these two things are coupled
together with a third thing which is uh
sexual infidelity
promiscuity fornication homosexuality to
the end of it and the and the messages
that are given by and large historically
and you know uh what is called maun you
know uh you know immoral poetry and
music and that sort of thing are
inviting people to things that are
unbefitting things that are unbefitting
things that are harmful you know the
criticism of some people who don't
deserve criticism the praise of some
people who don't deserve praise you know
um the extoling of the rulers you know
to or the uh praising of the rulers in a
way that is unbefitting or the
criticizing of the rulers in a way that
is unbefitting you know things that make
that encourage other people towards
violence against their opponents and
other cultures or other tribes or
families or that sort of thing you know
and you know historically music is
usually connected to drinking and
intoxicant and you know rry and that
sort of thing and you know Islam is a
religion of Simplicity and a religion of
ease and happiness without need for that
and this you know the the mafd the harms
that come you know from music and from
you know the use of musical instruments
and that sort of thing are weigh any
benefit that is there no right so just
as you know prison can say you know
taking a drink here there you know calms
my nerves or Makes Me Brave or something
of the sort we say yes that's the
benefit but the harms are away the
benefits and in Islam this is a
principle anything that the benefit
always alwayss the harm and is
permissible or legislated or commanded
or encouraged and and everything that
they harm outweighs the benefit is the
opposite is forbidden and it's bad it's
dislike according to the degree of its
harm right I mean and that's the thing
if you look at the core of all these
things alcohol music it it it evokes
emotion in people and again it boils
down to taking them away from you know
taking them away from the servitude of
Allah their God and Creator Our God to
the servitude of other than that to the
servitude and the slavery of theirselves
of their desires you know at the end of
the day if you look at all the things
that you know happen if you look at
crime rates you look at you know people
you know um things that happen in
regards to debuy and different forms of
vulgarity and all these different things
the core of it is always a lot of times
it's these two things music and alcohol
and as a matter of fact music is at the
core of all of them if you look at for
example the type of emotions that is
invoked you mentioned repetition and
stuff like that any one of us who grew
up in the US know especially in our
culture here in trinad and Tobago you
hear a song Sometimes you just hear one
word you remember a whole song and it's
stuck so it's a type of programming it's
a type of and whether or not you admit
it or not you realize that music does a
type of slavery upon you it enslaves you
you know and then you become a and I
think think you know not to get into too
much of conspiracy theory and stuff like
that but at the end of the day a lot of
the artists in the world today have come
out a lot of them admitting the fact
that you know um they were parts of
certain Cults that were that they used
music to control yeah to control the
masses of the people and so on and so
forth so that's why you have Jingles for
example when you get advertising and I
mean we could this topic is a broad
topic but Islam comes to stop all these
things Islam comes to prevent people
from worshiping the creation into
worshiping the Creator and any door that
we could close from that I think we have
that principle in Islam as well closing
the doors for that type of servitude
from the servitude of the creation to
the servitude of to bring back to the
servitude of the Creator that's the the
mission of Islam if you will for for a
better way have put in
it